you've got the Wolverine coming out it's
in a big big movie what was it like
being part of that probably one of the
more special movies I got to be a part
of just in terms of the experience and
working with James Mangold the director
Hugh Jackman and hiroyuki sanada was in
The Last Samurai just amazing people to
like look up to and see how they work
and and it just inspires me to try to do
better
Alissa who you like as an actor Hugh is
probably out of all the movies I've done
probably the nicest nicest guy I've
worked with very giving and he makes you
feel like one of his peers as opposed to
you know there's always the big
intimidation factor when you work with
an a-list you know level star of his
caliber and and he's you know I remember
shooting a scene where we have this big
confrontation and I felt like I was back
in acting class and it was just two guys
just you know rehearsing and working on
a scene together which was really really
cool
I think feelings felt to have that is
nothing yeah you know it's a rarity
because usually you know it's you work
with people at that caliber it's almost
like the in touchable area but he you
know he was and I think he ate with us
you know like we have the crew cafeteria
and he was with us almost every single
day
so it's cool tell us a little bit about
your character
why play a character named Harada and
all I can say is is that he he has is a
mysterious character who's kind of
relationships with several of the main
characters in the end the piece and you
kind of just have to watch the movie to
see how it actually turns out now you
fan of the movies the x-men movies
Wolverine and also and the comics as
well yeah I was a big fan of the comics
you know the x-men was was something I
grew up on and Wolverine of course was
one of my favorite characters you know
as far as the series goes that the x-men
franchise one of my favorites in the
Marvel Universe but I think this one is
going to set the whole new tone for for
the Wolverine franchise
just cuz I think James Mangold he has a
golden touch and I feel like there's
something very epic and scope about it
and bringing like the nuances of Japan
and Japanese culture and then I think
what Hugh brought to the queue brought
to the role this time is just you know
he's kind of down out and dirty and and
I like where it picks up you know with
this character tell me a bit about
filming on location we shot in Japan I
was there for about two two to three
weeks which was an amazing experience
it's one of the only places you feel
like you're not you know there's not a
Starbucks on every corner and you know
you're in Japan and then Australia was
amazing we shot most of the movie in
Australia and Australians gonna be nicer
what is it about EXO anything that makes
it so special I mean it's just the
characters I think Stanley created some
amazing characters as far as the
Wolverine goes you know the Clairemont
version of Logan going to Japan I think
you'll see
there's something special it's you know
what you can't go wrong with ninjas and
samurais how much kind of CG and stuff
like that be involved in on the though
you know we did a lot of the movie and
practical and I think James mango wanted
this movie to be very grounded so you
won't see too much CG and wants to be up
next to you will a new show called
intelligence I did with Josh Holloway
from los so another lost you know alumni
and it's a really cool sci-fi show that
will come out next year early next year
and what can we expect from your
character in that I play one of Josh's
nemesis and
and it's it's it's a really cool twist
on somebody with a super chip in his
head and I play the Nemesis who creates
the version 2.0 so we'll see what
happens but it's a really cool show how
much good is it playing the bike guy I
have a lot of fun you know but I you
know I love I love playing you know
someone like sangmin just because it's
he's bad but he's good and I don't do
much comedy and and I get to squeeze in
a little bit of that it's been lovely
talking to you well thanks so much for
your time yeah thank you
you